do you think
there's a sense where as putin sits now
in power for 22 plus years
he really dreams of a return
to uh
the power that influence
the
the land of stalin
so while you said that they're not in
the same place in terms of the numbers
of people
that suffered due to their regime
do you think he hopes to have the same
power
the same influence for a nation that was
in the 30s and the 40s and the 50s
of the 20th century under stalin
if he does lexi is deluding himself
we don't know for sure
very few people talk to him
very few people have access to him
a handful of
western leaders have met with him for
short periods of time
those inside russia barely meet with him
his own
minions in the regime barely have face
time with him
we don't know exactly what he thinks
it could be
that
he has delusions
of reconquering russian influence if not
direct control over the territories that
broke away
but it's not going to happen
let's talk a little bit about this guy
nikolai potherschev
nikolai patricev is probably not well
known to your listeners
he's the head
of russia's security council
and so
you could probably call him the second
most important or second most powerful
man in russia
certainly inside the regime
arguably navalny is the second most
important person in the country and
we'll talk about that later i'm sure in
terms of influence yes but but patrushev
is
a version of putin's right hand man
and path of chef
has been giving interviews in the press
you probably saw the interview with
nizarissa maya gazita not that long ago
he writes also his own blog like
interventions in the public sphere
using
the few channels that are left
and what's interesting about patrick
chev and and this
could well reflect similar thinking to
putin's which is why i'm bringing this
up
is that he's got this
conspiratorial theory
that the west has been on a
forever campaign
to destroy russia
just like it destroyed the soviet union
and that everything the west does
is meant to dismember russia
and that russia is fighting an
existential battle
against the west
and so for example the cia and the
american government wanted to bring down
the soviet union
never mind that the bush administration
the first bush the father
was trying desperately to hold the
soviet union together because they were
afraid of the chaos that might ensue
and the nukes that might get loose
as a result
of a soviet collapse and it was until
the very last moment
where bush decided his administration
decided
to back
those
republican leaders who were breaking
away from mikhail gorbachev and the
soviet union right
so never mind the empirics of it never
mind that bill clinton's administration
following george bush sent boatloads of
money
western taxpayer money to russia we
don't know exactly how much
because it came from different sources
people talk about how there was no
marshall plan it was tens of billions of
dollars
from various sources from the imf and
other sources and lex it disappeared
it's gone just like the german money
that went to gorbachev for unification
disappeared even before the soviet
collapse
the money disappeared but the west sent
the money
so how was that a plot and then you
could go all the way obama's
administration george bush trying to do
business deals and
reset the relations and obama
administration trying to reset the
relations and
and and doing nothing after the georgian
war and slapping
putin on the wrist
following
the seizure forcibly and you could go on
and you could go on all the way through
the trump administration telling putin
that he's right
trump believes putin and doesn't believe
u.s intelligence about russian efforts
to interfere in american domestic
politics so despite all the empirics of
it
you have patricia and likely putin
talking about this
multi-decade western conspiracy to bring
russia down
at the same time as that's happening the
germans are voluntarily increasing their
dependence on russian energy
voluntarily increasing their dependence
on russia so here's the conspiracy to
bring russia down
the french
who've
fantasized about themselves as a
diplomatic superpower
are constantly the french leaders are
constantly running to the kremlin to ask
what russia needs what concessions from
the west russia needs to be field to
feel respected again
the british
provide all manner of money laundering
and reputation laundering services for
the whole russian oligarchy including
the state officials
who are looting the state and using the
west british institutions to launder
their minds so all of this is happening
and yet patrochev imagines
this conspiracy to bring russia down by
the west and so that's what we've got in
the kremlin again
stalin had that same conspiratorial
mentality of the west
everything that happened in the world
was part of a western conspiracy
directed against the soviet union and
now directed against russia even though
the west is trying to appease
the west is offering its services the
west is trying to change russia through
investment in a positive way but but but
instead the west is what's changing the
west is becoming more corrupt western
services are being corrupted by the
relationship with russia
so so you have to ask yourself who are
these people in power and the kremlin
who imagine
that while they're availing themselves
of every service
and every blandishment of the west while
they're availing themselves of this
that
they're fighting a conspiracy by the
west to bring them down
so this is what they call
the
abijania
right
in russian which is a term as you know
that means those who are
resentful or you might call them the
losers the losers in the transition
so when the soviet union fell
and there was a diminishment
of a very substantial diminution and
russian power and influence in the world
a lot of people lost out
they weren't able to steal the property
they weren't able to loot the state in
the 90s
and they were on the outside
they gradually came back in
they were the losers in the transition
domestically
and for them
right they wanted to reverse
being on the losing side and so they
began to expropriate to steal the money
steal the property
from those
first
thieves
who stole in the 90s
and the 2000s and on have been about
re-stealing taking
the losers in the transition taking the
money from the winners
and reversing
this resentment this loser status
those are your path through chefs and
your putins
but at the same time this blows out
to
let's reverse the losses being on the
losing side the roiling resentment at
the decline of their power
internationally let's try to reverse
that too
so you have a profound psychological
a
whole generation of people who are on
the losing end domestically and reverse
that domestically that's what the putin
regime is about remember mikhail
khadrikovsky's
yukos
remember all the companies that are now
owned by putin cronies because they were
taken away from whoever stole them in
the first place
and now they're trying to do that on the
international scale
it's one thing to put domestic opponents
in jail
it's one thing to take away someone's
property domestically
but you're not going to reverse the
power of the west with the diminished
russia
that you have
and so that project
that patrick project
which we see him expressing again and
again he speaks about it publicly it's
not something that we need to
uh go looking for
a quest the secret we can't find it what
are they thinking it's right there in
front of our face and putin has spoken
the same way for a long time people
point to the 2007
speech at the munich security conference
that putin delivered and certainly your
listeners could use
a snippet or two of that just like they
could use a couple of quotes
from potter chef to contextualize what
we're talking about
but it predates the 2007 munich speech
the reaction to
ukraine's
uprising in 2004
attempt to
uh steal the election inside ukraine
right which the ukrainian people rose up
valiantly against and risked their lives
and overturned right so there were
public statements from putin already
back then the statements about
harakowski in 2003 when he was arrested
and expropriated
this is a long standing
psychological
deeply psychological issue which is
about managing russian power in the
world as i was saying the gap with the
west but has this further dimension of
feeling like losers and wanting to
reverse that that's their life
experience
abuse in there so there's that
resentment that fuels
uh this narrative uh fuels this
geopolitics and
um internal policy but so resentment is
behind some of the worst things that
have ever been done in human history
hitler was probably fueled by resentment
so resentment is a really powerful force
yes uh just to
maybe
not push back but to give fuller context
on the west you said the there's a
narrative
uh from from putin's russia
that the west is somehow an enemy you
position everything against the west
but is there a degree and to what degree
is the west willing to feed that
narrative that it's also convenient for
the west to have an enemy it seems like
in the place in the span
it seems like in geopolitics
having an enemy
is uh
useful for forming a narrative
now having an enemy for the basic
respect of humanity is not good but in
terms of maintaining power if you're a
leader in the game of geopolitics it
seems to be good to have an enemy
uh it seems to be good to have something
like a cold war we can always point your
finger and says all our actions are
fighting this evil whatever that evil is
it could be like with george w bush the
war on terror
terrorism is this evil you can always
point in something so you've made it
seem that the west is trying there's a
lot of forces within the west that are
trying to reach out a friendly hand
trying to help sending money
uh sending compassion trying to sort of
trying to integrate russia into global
institutions exactly which was a
long-standing multi-decade effort across
multiple countries and multiple
administrations in those countries but
is there also war mongers on the west of
course lex of course you're right about
that but let's put it this way people
talk about the cold war
and they're usually looking to assign
blame for the cold war as if it's some
kind of mistake
a misunderstanding or a search for an
enemy that was convenient to rally
domestic politics
so alex
there's a coup in czechoslovakia and
somebody installs a communist regime in
february 1948.
no reaction to that that's just okay
there's a blockade of berlin
is that cool by you
where they try to
strangle west berlin so that they can
swallow west berlin and add it to east
berlin you cool with that
how about
korean war invasion of
north korea
invasion of south korea by north korea
you cool with that
how about the murders and the show
trials up and down eastern europe
in the late 40s after the imposition of
the clone regimes you good with that
yeah it's very convenient to have an
enemy i agree with you but you know
there were some actions lex there were
some threats to people's freedom
there was some invasions there was some
aggression and violence on a mass scale
like collectivization of eastern europe
we could go on lex with the examples i'm
just given a few of them and so the cold
war was not a mistake
it was not a misunderstanding
we don't have to blame someone for the
cold war we have to give credit for the
cold war the truman administration
deserves credit for standing up to
stalin's regime for standing up to these
actions
for saying yeah
we're not just going to take this we're
not going to let this go on we're not
going to let this expand to further
territories we're going to create the
nato alliance and we're going to rally
democratic liberal regimes to stand up
to this illiberalism this violence and
this aggression and so yeah lex it's
always convenient to have an enemy
but there was an enemy
nikolai leona who recently died he died
in april
2022 and he had a major funeral he was
the last
head analyst of the soviet kgb
and leonif is one of the most important
figures for understanding the soviet
collapse and he has the best memoir on
the soviet collapse which is known in
russian as
ya
you will understand that
and and and you'll help your
your podcast listeners understand
there's a singularity to that kind of
expression li holetia
leonov just died but one of the things
he and in fact
the people who were supposedly arrested
by putin
as scapegoats for the ukraine war
the main ones sergey bessieda
gave the eulogy at leona's funeral in
april 2022
showing that it's a lie that all of
these people have been arrested and
purged and other nonsense
in social media
but to get back to what leonardo said
and get back to your enemy point
leona said you know the west spent all
this time blackening the image of the
soviet union all these resources and
propaganda
and covert operations to blacken the
soviet image and they did lex the west
did do that and then leona wrote in the
next sentence
and you know what we gave them a lot of
material to work with to blacken our
image
yeah so the
you're saying a kind of sobering
reality which it is possible to some
degree to draw a line between the good
guys and the bad guys
freedom is better than unfreedom likes
it's a lot better than on freedom and a
guy like you understands that really
well well so yes but those are all you
know there's wars like justice freedom
um
what else
love you can use a lot of words that
hitler himself used to describe
uh why he is actually creating a better
world
than those he's fighting so some of it
is propaganda the question is on the
ground what is actually increasing the
amount of freedom in the world
right we're not talking about propaganda
here when we use words like freedom
we're talking about rule of law
we're talking about protection of civil
liberties we're talking about protection
of private property
we're talking about an independent and
well-funded judiciary we're talking
about an impartial non-corrupt
competent civil service
we're talking about separation of powers
where the executive branch's power is
limited
usually by an elected parliament in fact
yes let's talk about elections
let's talk about freedom of speech and
freedom of the public sphere
we're not talking about freedom as a
slogan here we're talking about a huge
array of institutions and practices and
norms ultimately right and if they exist
you know and you live under them and if
they don't exist you fully understand
that as well right
ukraine
was a flawed democracy
before russia invaded
it's utterly corrupt
many ways dysfunctional especially the
elites were dysfunctional
the gas industry in ukraine was
absolutely terrible because of the
corruption that it generated the
oligarch problem
a handful of people stealing the state
resources and yet ukraine had an open
public sphere
and it had a parliament that functioned
and so despite its flaws
it was still
a democracy the regime in moscow you
can't say that lex
it's not a comparable regime to ukraine
you could say oh well there are
oligarchs in ukraine and there are
oligarchs in russia there's corruption
in ukraine there's corruption in russia
so really what's the big difference and
the answer is well
ukraine had the open public sphere
ukraine had a real apartment can you
call russia's duma
a real parliament i don't think so
i don't think you can
can you say that there were any checks
whatsoever on the executive branch
in russia can you say that the russian
judiciary had any independence
or really
full level of competence
even compared to the ukrainian judiciary
which was nothing to brag about no you
can't say that lex
so we can differentiate
between
the very flawed corrupt oligarch
oligarchic democracy in ukraine
and the very corrupt oligarchic
autocracy in russia i think that's a
fair distinction yeah we should say that
russia and ukraine have the great honor
of being the number one and the number
two most corrupt nations in europe by
many measures but there is a fundamental
difference as you're highlighting uh
russia is a corrupt autocracy
ukraine you can say is a corrupt
democracy
and um to that level there's a the
there's a fundamental difference
ukraine is not murdering
its own journalists
in systematic fashion if journalists are
killed in ukraine it's a tragedy if
journalists are killed in russia or
russian journalists are killed abroad
it's regime policy
and the degree to which a nation is
authoritarian
means that it's suffocating its own uh
spirit its
capacity to flourish it's uh we're not
just talking about
um sort of um the the freedom of the
press those kinds of things but
basically all industries uh get
suffocated and you're no longer being
able to
yeah flourish as a nation grow the the
production the gdp the scientists the
art the culture all those kinds of
things yes lex you're absolutely right
and so
before the invasion the full-blown
invasion of february 2022 into ukraine
because as you know the war has been
going on for many years at a lower level
compared to what it is these days but
still a tragic war with many deaths
prior to february 2022
before this latest war we could have
said
that the greatest victims of the putin
regime are russian
domestic
that the the people who are suffering
the most from the putin regime
are not sitting here in new york city
but in fact they're sitting there in
russia
now of course with the invasion of
ukraine and and really
the
atrocities
that have been well documented
and more are being investigated
uh it we can't easily say anymore that
russians are the greatest victims of the
putin regime
but in in ways other than bombing and
murdering civilians
children mothers
grandmothers grandfathers
after you include that
then of course the larger number of
victims of the putin regime are not
ukrainians but ultimately russians and
and there's how many of them now that
have fled
you